[Music]
welcome to ear biscuits I'm link and I'm
Rhett it's time for another conversation
with someone interesting from the
internet and this week our guest at the
roundtable of dim lighting is long time
youtuber vlogger and video artist
Mitchell Davis started his channel live
lava live all the way back in May 2007
and he's currently got 650 thousand
subscribers in over 100 minimum of a
million a total view since then now he's
a comedic vlogger he's also a visual
artiste
he's artsy guy and so we you know we
talk about those two different worlds
and he actually recently combined those
onto his main channel just a matter of
months ago right but we really can't do
justice to his visual art video you have
to watch because they're well yeah
they're visual to watch the visual one
but it's mesmerizing footage
intoxicatingly edited is how I would
describe it good word so it's you know
you know that thing on the iTunes
visualizer
I don't usually turn that on but I
remember like way back in the day the
first time I ever started listening to
music on iTunes what is this flower
button and I press that and the whole
screen turns into memorising
intoxicating yeah it turns into this
like like this graphic flower that
morphs over time so when you're
listening to I don't know John Denver
John Denver's are very excited yes I'm
doing no justice don't watch it well
we're just wetting your appetite so you
will appetite so you will go watch him
but another thing about Mitchell
now first of all I've always thought
that he's just an incredibly funny dude
only person and online and in terms of
vlogging hit some of his vlogs or some
of the funniest vlogs I have ever found
on YouTube here's an example of one
because you don't have to see this when
you can hear it to find out how funny it
is it's called the panty-dropper so I
don't know if you guys know this but
I've talked about it a little bit in the
past year on live love live but I like
Cologne
I like wearing Cologne I don't know why
but when I wear it I feel like I'm
invincible I steal I've been wearing the
same cologne for a really long time like
a long time and to be totally honest the
only reason that I wore this cologne
that I actually picked is because when I
walked into the Cologne store as a young
woman I almost said as a young woman I
walked into a cologne store as a young
woman when I walked into the store full
of fragrances IV lines right for the the
woman who was in charge and I said hi
I'm Mitchell and I'm looking for
something to make me smell better but
like what hennas smell are you looking
for I'm not sure exactly well if you're
not really sure we have this one and
everybody buys it and all the dudes who
work there a panty-dropper is the truth
and I think that's what makes it funny
so she got the bottle when I smelled it
and it was actually pretty nice and I've
been wearing it ever since and it's been
a joke ongoing that I bought it because
it's a panty dropper but realistically
it wasn't now when a guy's been vlogging
for seven years you might think that you
know everything about him if he'd been
following him right but the interesting
thing that we find out in there this
year biscuit is that there was a whole
lot of stuff going on that he wasn't
necessarily sharing with his audience at
the time because that this really
becomes a quintessential ear biscuit
where the the curtain is pulled back a
little bit and it gets personal I'm
right this is a really good episode when
Mitchell showed up I was like why is he
wearing a curtain yeah because he's pink
so he can clean her behind so he can
pull it back and you get to see you get
to hear what's under the curtain in this
ear biscuit I mean things did get
personal we talked about weathering the
perceived rejection of his mom at a
young age his bout with a paralyzing
case of OCD and facebooking the father
that he never knew and we talk about
from a professional standpoint how he
strikes the balance between being a
vlogger and an artist and specifically
how he decided to kind of go the artist
route in spite of all the pressures to
just be a YouTube teen idol teen idol
teen idol you said it okay here it is
enjoy our air biscuit with Mitchell
Davis
[Music]
the other night um see the the streamys
reception the one where we lost the
streamys before the streamys yes yes the
pre streamys yeah the one where we could
have won an award and that you hosted
but it was me and I was that a real
stream I just that we didn't win an
award it was all up to me too and I was
like who do I want no I mean you were
making the decision yeah I was making
decisions well and I think we all are on
the same page of knowing that we
shouldn't have won that category and we
didn't sign it back to in education but
I sauce won congratulations girls had to
Michael I did notice that you hid your
co-host on the head with the microphone
I did I did
and was that planned no no none of it
was planned almost was Shira Shira yes
she was it was kind of like a last
minute thing where they were like do you
want to co-host and I had never
co-hosted anything and I've never hosted
anything so I was just like very nervous
about it actually and I was just like
sure but no scripts for me just like
tell let her do her thing and I'll just
kind of like squeeze in jokes and kind
of just keep it light and funny and she
was going so fast in there was no time
for jokes that eventually I was just
like what's the best joke I could do
without having to tell a joke I'm a
Bopper on the head because like one the
sound of a mic hitting anything is just
great it's just that right and well the
sound that you expected shira's had to
make says a lot about what you thought
of Shira so tread lightly at this point
I wasn't expecting it to be like or like
anything like that I'm just saying I
I've been here Chinese if it made it
Gong sound I would've been amazing yeah
well I'm just asking what you expected I
just I just thought it would be
hilarious and you know what
I laughed real hard about it so it
clearly worked I didn't see it happen
you saw it hi
I saw it happen and they knew that it
knew that a it wasn't planned yeah I
knew that from the look I did it but
what was the look described it the look
was well she actually said it she was
like that actually hurt yes she said
that actually yeah
I found it all very entertaining I do
want to say thank you yeah I just
thought I thought you know just add a
little bit of some strangeness to it but
I was just like oh they gonna talk about
this afterwards what was your what was
your response to that actually hurt did
you
I said I'm so sorry I didn't think it
actually would did with my phone so yeah
but uh no I just thought it was like the
perfect joke she was talking so fast
sometimes so I was just like you know
what what you thought it would like
bloop bloop
and did you decompress that later you
know as soon as it was over I was like
I'm so sorry if that really hurt and she
was it I mean it was fine but I was just
like it was it was for the joke was one
of those it was one of those
free-for-all events anyway oh yeah happy
hour so it's just like kind of crazy so
that's that's one of the reasons I was
like game to like yeah I'm gonna try it
out for the first time hosting let's do
it this time in like she just read it
all and I basically just got to chime in
whenever oh yeah well I I enjoyed the
comic relief thanks for one good in
watching back through videos across your
career in preparation for our
conversation one of the things that
struck me was the whole you know how
some creators will put an annotation at
the beginning of a video that will pop
up and be like be sure to watch in HD
which I think was a big thing when you
could first have that option we all had
the option of educating our audience to
click on that little whatever it was at
the time now it's like a little gear on
the YouTube player where you can then
change it to HD and now it's you know if
you shot this thing in 4k or 5k you can
choose 4 or 5 K to watch the thing if
you're if your internet can handle it
yeah who is watching youtube videos in
4k that's the people who shot it and
uploaded yeah I think I'm like where's
the 4k button on my cell phone that's
the quick cuz I'm watching a lot of
YouTube on my phone and I've like kind
of made a rule with myself that I'm
never gonna go over 720 no really
there's no point no no yes
no kid is ever being like oh man
let this thing buffer cuz I gotta watch
it in 5k but especially on phone but the
thing that occurred to me was when I
think about your content
I actually think about that like the
training as an audience member to switch
to HD actually is engaged when watching
your content because I want to you
always
make sure you make artistic choices with
everything you do
even if I'm I mean I never thought I
would watch anyone's what I would call a
vlog okay yeah and have a desire to bump
that up to HD and to make sure I wasn't
missing anything but I I think that sums
up how I now see you and I think well I
see you in HD that is well I'm glad you
do when I watch you I want to watch the
I'm watching the choices that you're
making and it's it's it's very funny
it's very fascinating it's very engaging
but I don't want it that to be
compromised you know it's kind of like
when I go to a movie theater I want to
go to the ArcLight here in town because
they is the let is the least likely to
have a compromised experience I'll pay a
little bit more for that and I think
that's a testimony to who you are and
what one of the things I'd like to
explore in this conversation is that you
make those type of choices that I want
to click on the HD but it's fascinating
because a lot of times it's it's you
could just describe it as a vlog yeah I
I've I've often called it vlogging plus
is where I know that it's just a vlog
but I I I really try to stylize it I
really try to make it I just try to take
it to an artistic level of where if if
the audio was turned off and music was
just playing you'd still want to be able
you'd still want to watch it you'd still
think like this is visually pleasing I
like the way this looks like even though
I'm not exactly sure what he's talking
about do you have a better is it easier
for you to describe your work and
summarize what you do or or to describe
who you are like I'm a youtuber or I'm a
fill-in-the-blank I always just try to
I'm just an artist I'm just a digital
artist just try
to get away with whatever I can but
comedian I mean what what what do you
throw in there yeah I mean it kind of
depends on the situation I mean yeah I
do tell jokes a lot of times and then
sometimes I do like the most avant-garde
like what is this yeah so it's kind of
just that's why I've always just gone
with artists because I feel like
comedians are artists and so where is
almost Pablo Picasso so it's just kind
of like this like catch-all phrase that
I can use is just like well you tubers a
catch-all phrase to it no you're right
but not all of my artwork is on YouTube
so that's kind of where it kind of it
for me it I want to I want to make sure
that they understand that's not my only
home like I am on soundcloud I'm you
know I'm doing things in the real world
physical world and I'm selling prints so
I I you're selling prints the artist I'm
selling prints the artist all the vinyls
go to missions on it but yeah so it just
it ended up just kind of being this just
the one word that kind of fit well you
know it's I would say in addition to
wanting to click on the HD button on
your content I would describe it as
thoughtful and you have a certain amount
of conviction there's a commitment to
something that goes beyond I am just
here to play this game I'm here to play
this YouTube game so I I want to get at
where that comes from you know this is
an ear biscuit we're going into your ear
hole yeah you guys into the brain going
inside my brain right now and and so I
you know I'm assuming that as is often
the case I want to I want to find out
about like what was life like before
this whole thing happened that led to
this thoughtfulness that you exhibit you
exhibited from the beginning in your in
your content so we know you're from Ohio
but that's about it that's that's what
we know yeah what else so you want me to
start from the beginning were you born
in Ohio I was born in Daytona Florida Oh
Daytona Florida you can drive on the
beach there and I was born and I
basically was like I was there for like
a week or two and then my mom came back
and lived with my grandma and we lived
there for a long time so you were like
two weeks old oh yeah I was like a just
a little tiny just a turd of a baby they
just moved me to Ohio so was this like a
split situation like a parent split
situation I think it was from what I
understand I don't know a whole lot
about this I never met my real dad I
still haven't and I think it was just
kind of she had the baby and which me
she had me baby Mitchell the baby
Mitchell and I think she just realized
like oh this isn't where I want him to
grow up this is not the environment so
from what I've heard I know very little
I didn't even find out that who I
thought was my real dad wasn't my real
dad until I was like a teenager and
really yeah because I thought that when
we when we when she moved back to Ohio
she met a man and they ended up getting
married and I just always assumed that
was my real bad until I started middle
school and they asked for my they asked
for like some paperwork and I noticed
the name was different and I was like
hold up wait a second and that and and
so like literally I just remember what
do you mean the name was different like
my last name was different and is the
first time you had thought about that
yeah I'd been like oh that's strange
what that that never really registered
with me and my dad so your dick yeah
your dad's last name was not Davis yeah
it was Evans so is uh Evans was on that
form and I was just like why would they
why would they ever put Evans that
doesn't make any sense and so I was we
were in line at a bank and I just
randomly had like the Epiphany moment I
looked up I was like he's not my real
dad is he and she was just like we need
to go home don't we you know yeah yeah
so it was just like this weird moment
where I was just like holy gosh she make
her deposit or did you leave the line
immediately uh she made her deposit and
then we went home I mean it was just
such a it was such a weird bombshell it
kind of I think it it should have shook
me a lot more than it did if anything no
it was just kind of like okay I mean I
get it but it doesn't I mean I still
feel the exact same after I just figured
it all out but at the time did we was
your mom still with the boyfriend that
you had thought was
the husband and yes yes but we I had
never weren't adopted by him no no I was
never really and and you know it to this
day I never still really clicked with
anyone my mom has been married to or
date or anything I've always just kind
of been like if anything I've always
just kind of just been like the real the
real parent in my life has always been
my grandparents and you know my Winnie
didn't Leon shout out grandparents
they're the best they got good names too
because you ended up living with them I
guess is that from one of the first I've
lived with my great I've lived with my
grandparents like on and off I mean I
might move with them again they're the
best they're like the coolest old people
I've ever come in contact with to the
point where I'm like throwing them in
videos and stuff because they're so
funny to me was the first video that you
put your granddad and the one where you
were kind of talking about I'm sorry I
haven't made videos like in the first
few months
oh your earliest videos you can see your
granddad in there and it's like I've got
all this footage I don't know how to
make videos you've got this great
footage of my granddad yeah and then you
cut to it yeah and that and that was all
totally staged - I was just like I did
not have any extra footage I was just
like I'm just I just had this idea where
I was like what if I made a video about
how I can't make a video which I mean is
like my real problem all the time but I
like kind of playing with that idea and
so he would always just barge in my room
and and he just got like this really
intense like he would always sit in
front of my computer and like tap on the
thing and be like messing up your videos
metree you better watch out and I'm just
like get out of here and so he would
just kind of we became it was like this
weird older brother situation if I was
the older brother and yeah in this video
you were trying to get him to say live
lava live rock yes and he just couldn't
get it out of his mouth it was just like
rocks rocks that's great thank you and
then he walks away but then he comes
back in and picks up your chair yeah I
thought he was gonna beat you like
pro-wrestler Stein no and see and that's
like the brother stuff is is he just
picked it up and then you just put it
right back down but I as soon as he
picked it up I just went with it and I
was just
like oh man I'm about to just start
screaming because it's gonna be
hilarious yeah
yeah he's just a he's wild he's so cool
though did he have an accent I mean see
ok everyone thinks he has an accent he
had a stroke he had a stroke and he was
like the most boring grandfather I ever
had and then he had a stroke and
everybody kind of got I don't want to
say afraid of him
but everyone kind of got like a little
distant like his his like closer family
and then I had all these issues with my
family so I ended up living with them
and so I became this like older brother
kind of guy who was like constantly
chatting with him and really being
interested in this like new person that
was in our lives like we were living
there with kind of a stranger he was
different he was different his voice
changed he the accident kind of started
happening he started singing a lot like
a lot of things kind of changed I mean
when he first came to he didn't remember
anything except for the Kentucky
Wildcats lineup from the 80s so he was
just like and I while everyone else was
like this is so awful I I was like this
is really interesting
uh-huh and like I've had multiple
conversations with him about how he had
to learn how to read again as an adult
and and I got to talk to him about what
it was like living those few months not
knowing words and that was really that
that was special to me because he was
just so raw and real and he still is
with me when I asked no question there's
no filter he will he will tell me the
truth and and I just he became one of my
best friends he just yeah so what
precipitated you moving in with your
grandparents specifically and was that
before the stroke it was it was after so
like I didn't like fully live there when
he when it happened but it was soon
after is my mom was dating a guy who we
did not get along and it kind of just
became like a him or me and I just
packed up my stuff and went and how are
you but it wasn't it was that an
ultimatum from your mom or that was like
your perspective on it it was an
ultimatum it was like it was me and him
kind of just looking at her and in it
just is like I could tell that she
wasn't moving or budging at the time and
I decided to get out and just be happier
and you were a teenager yeah yes and
this is before I started YouTube this is
uh this is yeah I was a teenager in any
other any brothers and sisters I have a
younger sister who I still chat with all
the time she still lives with my mom and
and and incense I've I've you know made
peace with her and we're cool now and
but you didn't get along with her either
no I didn't get along with her after
well after that whole like him or me and
then all of a sudden I ended up leaving
it was kind of like apparently Oh men
you'd what happened so I I was just like
give me I literally like took like a
year or two and was just like very quiet
I didn't talk to anyone on the side of
the family I just kind of lived in in my
own bubble world and my grandparents
house hanging out with Leon and hanging
out finita hmm because I guess at that
age it felt like I mean my mom has
chosen him over me yeah being a
rejection from your mom basically well
yeah and then not knowing my dad it just
kind of felt like well sheesh I don't
think I have parents right now and but
the thing is though is I never looked at
it like as this is awful is I kind of
thought like there a lot of
self-discovery happened you know I was
taking care of myself you know and and
it was really interesting to all of a
sudden be in charge of me and and my
grandparents are just kind of you know
grandparents are they just they just
want the best for you but they're also
your grandparents so they're like double
nice and so you know if I wanted a
computer in my room all of a sudden it
was like that was doable like yeah of
course you can have the computer in your
room and it's like okay now when you
found out you know at the bank about the
about your dad not being here your real
dad did that give you a sense of okay
well I got to figure this out now when
you went home what was the conversation
like and then have you ever said I'm
going to figure this
I'm gonna go make contact um at the time
it was kind of just like I just want to
know the truth and that's it so that's
what I did and then for a long time I
mean this is before you know I was the
biggest thing I was doing online at the
time was maybe live journal you know so
it wasn't like I was like let me go hop
on Facebook I mean so honestly I didn't
really care because I was just like well
if he hasn't hung out or even tried to
reach out since then then why would I
waste my time yeah cuz the thing I was
thinking was sometimes when one relation
you know if you've got if you the
relationship with your mother was
suffering there might you might be like
well I'm gonna go find my dad yeah but
the fact that he hadn't tried to even
make contact I was just like you know I
don't think he's gonna want to see me
either so it was just kind of and like I
said I have my grandparents and they've
just been fantastic so I was just like I
mean I didn't even really ask I just
remember I called my grandma and I was
just like I think I'm gonna live with
you guys again and she was like I'll
come pick you up later today she got it
she got it she knew like she knew what
was going on and and I was just like
thanks and to this day I still think it
was one of the best decisions I ever
made I'm out like I living with them put
a different perspective especially with
Leon it was just this friendship that I
I really really appreciated I mean he
really would I could just I could ask
him these questions and I could really
dive into this this mind and I and I
know that he appreciates it and I know
that he also I mean we're like best
friends we're each other's favorite dude
like we just think we just you're just
so cool I mean I love hanging out with
him anytime I get a chance I every
Monday I always go have dinner with them
mhm so it doesn't sound like you were
teetering on depression as a masseur
teen 14 year old kid or no I don't think
so I mean I think I was definitely like
having like moments you know I'd world
every kid has moments you know where
you're just like this sucks
yeah but I don't think I ever really let
it affect me too much if anything I just
kind of I just kind of felt like what am
I missing every once in a while just
like what am I missing like
a great example is like a couple weeks
ago I was at my girlfriend's house and
we were all having a barbecue and I and
I just looked at her and I was just like
you know I don't know how to use a grill
I have no idea how to use a grill and
she's like didn't anyone ever teach you
and I was like no I was like the only
dude in my life is Leon and there's no
way he's getting in front of a girl
right now I was like and and I was just
like like that like like moments like
that was like dang it I missed that
that's you know shaving like my grandma
taught me how to shave you know and and
just like those small little things but
again I I think it definitely helped
mold who I am today and so I don't
really I'm not like like bummed about it
if anything I'm like that's what makes
me me is I have these like weird little
things that happened well I think that's
I mean you go through something like
that and it's it's telling it's kind of
it not only it forms who you are and
then it it but it reveals who you are
you know if if there's a if you're an
optimistic person or there seems you
seem to exude a lot of positivity and
and the things you do even the choices
you make it's it seems like this could
have been an opportunity to discover
that about yourself yeah and like it
like I was saying there was a lot of
self-discovery
especially with when I moved and all of
a sudden it was like okay if it's if
it's if it's just gonna be me what are
we gonna do what's gonna happen so and
so just to just to close the dad part of
it
what Rhett was asking so where does that
stand now did you ever did you ever
change your mind - I reach out or figure
out who he was actually this past year I
I got on Facebook and I did some like
some deep searching and I'm pretty sure
what led to it what led to it is this I
had this one moment with my girlfriend
right now and I just like I just
randomly started crying we were sitting
on the couch or something and I was just
like me and I want to know what his face
looks like I just want to know what his
face looks like right now at this moment
for no reason other than just curiosity
I was just like I want to know what his
face looks like and and is there a book
where I could see is
face there is there was and I am I found
what did she say she said like go for it
she she started searching because she
was like I know that there's no way you
can do it and I and I knew exactly what
she meant is if I were to do it in
hypothetically he were to see my youtube
or something then it could potentially
it was it would really mess with me if
he wanted to talk to me just because of
that mm-hmm
that would really just not work so we
started using her account we found it
and I printed off there's some screen
grabs and because you knew his name yes
and I'm your mom and I I do his name
yeah so I just printed off like three
and then I went over to my mom's house
and showed her three and she was just
like it was like a line up and she
pointed and she's like that's definitely
him and I was just like okay thanks and
then I closed it and that's it just
wanted to know what he looked like yeah
it was just like a random like breakdown
moment where I was just like I want to
know what and I think it just hadn't had
a lot to do with the fact that it was I
was like I'm aging now I'm getting older
and I was just like half of me is this
stranger and half of me is worried what
if something's really wrong with him I
want to be able to have that option if I
go to the doctor and they're like mmm
does heart disease run in your family
you know like I want to be able to be
like no but I know who to ask if
something does happen but I you know I'm
I'm good I mean really at the end of it
I'm just like but what did you see in
the photo whenever your mom said that's
him
what did you see it's kind of like I I
just saw a stranger that I have a weird
piece of yarn tied to that's like tied
to my finger wait his that we never even
know is there that's what it kind of
felt like it was just kind of like it's
like when when you see someone fall and
you help them pick up all their things
and then that you walk away and you're
like I'm never gonna see them again but
that was that was a nice moment it was
mmm I felt the same in my gut with that
except it was just kind of like yeah we
have a weird connect
but neither of us will ever really know
about it or think about it again if
right now in my life he was like I want
to meet you I'd be like too late mmm
yeah you you missed your opportunity man
I'm an adult now and I don't need
another person that's I mean a stranger
you know what I mean I mean I'm 25 years
old I you missed your opportunity yeah
so what were you during that same time
from from a from a personal perspective
you said you were doing some stuff on
online mm-hmm but I gotta assume you
were an artistic kid well what were you
doing with your free time and how are
you expressing yourself well when it
came to artistically online I had a I
had another channel before live level
live I had another channel where I was
just I was like speed drawling and speed
painting like you know whether you like
that music in the background I had a
whole channel where I was just doing
that like from the get-go of YouTube so
it wasn't it was early yeah I was doing
it and and to the point where more
people watched it than I knew and then I
deleted it cuz it freaked me out because
I was like oh that's terrifying an
audience was terrifying at the time it
was and then and then I kind of like let
it sit in and a few months later I was
like okay I think I get this I'm gonna
try it again and you were 16 well I was
a little older I was 17 18 by the time I
like really got into live level if I had
just started high school and yeah and I
decided to do that and what specifically
because even some of those earliest
videos are deleted now yeah I mean it
was the black and white videos yeah my
black and white of my whole black and
white stuff I mean I just I just made
them just cuz I there's just pure
passion I just liked making them but you
I mean what you were watching other
youtubers like I mean I imagine you
would see Smosh you're like okay that
well am I gonna do that or kinda if
anything I was watching like Waverly
films and me me Molly and ResNet
I don't more of a New York yeah axe
hominid accidentally just robbed type
thing I was just watching it was like
vlogging from me me Molly where she did
like a she was doing all these videos
that were I thought were really
interesting and in Fresno it was just so
quick and I I just thought like I want
to do that that seems fun and at the
side simultaneously I'm like having the
worst time with anxiety and and it's
just kind of a build-up so I was just
like oh this is cool I'm now I can't at
least use it and kind of put things out
there without having to go out there by
that point you had a couple of years at
least or a high school careers worth of
YouTube under your belt where you had
developed a fanbase right well no no
because not at first
I mean it took it took a minute for
anyone to start watching my my YouTube
stuff but I like I remember loading it
on my phone and like showing some what
some of the kids in my class like
something I just made and they're like
what are you doing here what what is
this like um because I went to one of
those school like um I went to a career
school during high school my last two
years and I went for commercial arts
okay so I was going for commercial arts
but I was spending all my free time
making videos so I was like kind of
using that aesthetic of like logos I
mean that's that's where why I always
say logo like it came because I was so
used to making logos like during the day
I was like that I was like that's my
life but then this is my fun and then
you know it kind of realized like oh no
these are mixing it's kind of mm-hmm
colliding together and I can I can make
these videos look just as nice as these
logos but it was vlog based
stream-of-consciousness comedy that you
didn't found in an edit yeah yeah I
would just at the first few videos I
ever posted were most of I mean it was
just my eye sight I turned it on and I
would just kind of record myself for
like 40 minutes talking about things
that I saw on the Internet out of
context and then I would and then I cut
there was a day where I cut one up and I
was like let's leave
let's delete all the actual talk and
let's leave in all the weird parts the
middle parts the parts that you normally
would have delete in that experiment
yeah in an artistic experiment and I
crushed it all together and I titled the
video Kanye West and that's when I got
like a response to or people were like
this is so weird and funny and I don't
know what he's talking about or anything
and I was just like okay so you guys
want like the other stuff the stuff
that's not necessarily makes sense and
that's what makes it funny
is this like random okay and so and
let's be honest you also had a certain
look that at the time was was it was the
best - it was a giant moustache describe
the look metal I mean it was just you
know just like a young guy with long
hair it was just like a swoopy yeah I
was like a long emo scene kind of
looking guy wearing v-necks all the time
okay so you begin to get traction and
did you have a sense at the time of the
demographic that you were getting
traction with because because that's
what I feel like they're you're kind of
teetering you've always kind of been
teetering between this but especially in
the beginning between like teen vlog
star and artist right yeah and so that
initial an initial traction where did
you think it was coming from I think
that's well I would love to say that
that is the forever struggle with live
level it for me is just like I just feel
like no one will ever take it seriously
as an art as something art were you
thinking that at the time yes as well
right I mean I've always kind of thought
that I mean I've always loved telling
jokes and I love making people laugh and
that's great but I've always you know
wanted it to be a piece of art live lava
live I mean the name I still hold very
dear cuz it's that's and I still won't
tell anyone what it means because it's
it was my my big art epiphany of when I
came up with it and I and that's it was
that was everything I do technically are
related is live lava live
and you keep that to yourself and yes
you're going to take that to your grave
no no I actually made a promise that if
and it's like I said of course if I'm
ever on your biscuits what it means ya
know I've always said to viewers that if
you know I get a million subscribers
I'll sit down unedited and upload a
video telling you exactly what it means
oh and I I don't think that'll ever
happen but you know what I I had I you
know I got asked about it so much that I
was like okay I gotta figure out a way
to like equalize like make it so that I
can just throw a bone out there without
actually saying it so that's that was
the deal that I made years ago well
we're gonna tell you a story from our
perspective that I think will you will
find entertaining but will also get kind
of is a picture of that that moment at
time seven eight nine we were there yes
and first ever Wow was that no YouTube
live had happened in oh yeah I watched
it from home but this was the second
time we had ever been to first quote
gathering would ever been to my second
like YouTube in real life thing after
YouTube July 8 2009 I mean sorry August
yeah 7 7 7 8 now July 8 2009 that was
the date May 7 8 9 yeah in Manhattan and
we were all gonna meet in central
organized by like just a handful of fans
who weren't they didn't have huge
subscriber news on YouTube really just
there's a just group of people I mean I
remember I met with them in the hotel
lobby and I was just like I don't know
what I'm doing here I've never been in
anything like this and they were like
nobody knew what we were doing right you
know what nobody and when we we showed
up to the like the first gathering that
was in Central Park and link and I were
just like this is so cool people are
coming out to us and saying a few people
a few people you know a handful of
people we've seen your videos and we're
like oh there's there's fans let me know
us in real life there's people who
showed up here to meet people like us
not just us but people like us and they
recognized us and then there because the
typical mythical beast which
they weren't called that at a time was
not the type we had a following but it
was not the type of following that would
show up at a seven eight nine it wasn't
a a core youtuber following we were it
was kind of like a we had a fringe
different thing but this is our first
exposure to that the YouTube culture fan
culture yeah yeah no same with me and
we're just walking so we're just walking
around at the park no organization what
it's just like standing around and then
people kind of just people a couple of
people will come up to us a couple and
then some a person would show up that
was a more popular youtuber at the time
and people were kind of scurry over
there I thought if shaycarl
showed up and in a kind of a crowd kind
of gathered and then all of a sudden
there's like a stirring a stirring that
a lot and then a line had to be formed
yeah and it was like oh it's an
unprecedented amount of organization at
such a chaotic thing like a line
wrapping around the whole park
basically like everything and at that
point I had no idea that anything like
that was about to happen I had no idea I
I I tried to get out of going to seven
eight nine cuz I was so like anxiety
ridden I was like yeah now to know that
that anxiety was such an issue and I
like like seven eight nine in the hotel
was my grandma just like just she I was
like I'm not going alone I can't go
alone and I went with her and then I had
Kevin meet me from district lines and we
walked down there and all of a sudden it
was just like a flood of people and I
was like what is going on yeah you were
the guy at the end of the line that you
didn't know whatever form it was bizarre
it was bizarre
I mean and that's when I met you guys
you guys like squeezed in and I really
got in the line I just remember being
like first off I met you that was the
first time I ever met you guys in real
life and I just thought you're so tall
you both are so dr. Giants your tree
people and then I remember just
instantly having of the flip cam and
just like basically
basically I pressured you into making
supernote again I was like it was the
coolest thing ever you guys got to do it
again and I just remember I was just
like wouldn't shut up about Superman as
soon as you guys walked away I was like
yeah because then it was 2008 the first
Super note the that's how we that's the
first exposure we had to you was this
really popular person on the Internet
made a super note and we heard about
immediate because everybody's talking
about it it was it was you and it was it
was for the shaped hard rebellion I yes
yep
yeah the most high-profile super note
that wasn't a captain and we so we were
extremely flattered and that's why we
were glad to stand in your line and
finally super cool I was just like this
is what this is what I wanted to see on
YouTube I was like this is like that
weird you're you you guys were using it
and I was like they get it that everyone
gets like you were one of those people
that I was like they're using it in such
a smart way and in a way to interact and
I just thought that it was almost like
it was a big art installation project it
was so cool to me and the fact that you
were gonna like combine all of them
together and then make one long note I
was just like that is so cool to be a
part of something like that but the
seven eight-nine experience was so I
opening for us it sounds like it was
four you know it it's to this day is
still the reason it's when I say I
started I changed from I I considered
myself becoming a youtuber that day
because I realized like the community
that day that's the day that I realized
like there was a lot more because like
before then I had never subscribed to
anyone I'd I'd only like casually
watched I didn't get that there was like
this momentum growing like a people I
didn't get that I I just kind of thought
like oh everyone else is just doing the
same thing we're all just doing her own
thing and I don't know and so what
changed
at that point when you went back home I
subscribed to everyone that I met there
and then all of a sudden I was like whoa
the websites completely different now
it's it's it's not just an uploader and
me watching things but it's like it was
a lot more of like a stream and chatting
with people and and then getting to see
more
just like the viral things like I was
staying in contact all the time and you
can thank quatre if ik Shawna Nana Lou
and Mika kitty because they they like
basically cornered me after I got there
and they were like you need to get
involved in the community everybody
you're here but why are you here and I
was like what do you mean and they were
like you you don't ever talk to anyone
what are you doing here you you either
you need to start subscribing and chat
with all of us or get out of here and I
just remember I was kind of like shocked
but at the same time I was like okay
cool this is cool this is like my intro
I was like initiated into it or
something and yeah they they made me a
youtuber instead of just like this guy
using the platform and you guys did the
vlog vet o'clock vertica that's the
whole reason vlog vetting existed is
because they like open my eyes to so
much that we just the whole weekend
we're joking like we need to start a
channel together you guys don't you guys
can help me start getting used to
communicating on here and so it was a
new channel called that then you had
certain days of the week that you were
assigned to upload yes and it was really
I mean it was never that serious it was
never anything that we were all like
this is it it was just kind of like a
cool way for us to keep in contact
forcefully you know it was kind of just
like and why not do it on YouTube but
that's we all know how to use it before
that it was kind of the whole Kyle who
presumably was your best friend I guess
forever is you know and in the way that
right now we started making videos
together it seemed like that the plan
was you and Kyle we're gonna make videos
together you know he moved away there
was there was this parallel story with
him mm-hmm that then at certain points
he would kind of dip into the channel
yeah
but then life would kind of take the
creative endeavor apart or something ya
know we used to joke that you guys were
the adult versions of us actually like
we were like that'll be us right and
yeah man um yeah it was it was a I this
kind of okay so Kyle really started to
get serious getting into it after I got
really
I started college and I was still doing
videos and what year was this was this
after seven eight nine or I graduated in
oh wait so it was it was a year and then
and then some I think either way I was
about to start I was about to start
college and we had a giant windstorm and
all the power went out and I realized
that I kind of was paralyzed not
paralyzed really but I was like I was
very afraid to get out of my bed and we
we found out it was because I couldn't
do my routines I couldn't do the things
and that's when everyone kind of
realized like oh no this is this is not
just like casual oh he's so OCD it was
like no he was very I to the point where
I was like I would just I wouldn't step
out of my room I was like trapped and
then even when the power came back on I
just I think it was out for two weeks I
just I ended up having to pull myself
out of school because I realized I
needed to go see doctors and and focus
on that before I tried to continue a
career in anything and so I did that
when you said pull yourself out of
school you mean College yes okay I
pulled myself out of college to do that
and but at the same time I was caught
I'm still doing YouTube because at the
same time it was just like but this is
still a cool way to connect I can it's
like I'm still out there without having
to go out there so that's what I was
doing and then when I started to get
better when I started getting the
medicines and starting feeling better I
said to myself I'm not going back to
school I'm gonna make YouTube my life so
how bad did it get I mean was the wind
storm the low point or did it get it was
the oil it was the eye-opener it was
just the eye-opener that what I was
doing was not was not
I couldn't just get away with it anymore
like it so you were hiding it from
others and yourself
a little bit from myself pretty much
from others you know like like one of
the a big moment that I always I'm
always like that was I should have I
should have taken that as a bigger
moment is I remember I was trying to
make my bed and I kept making my bed
over and over
over again and I kept I kept throwing
away my pillows until I and I could only
have one of things and it was getting my
life was getting not minimal but just
like okay what's what do you mean you
had to throw away all your pillows and I
was like they all didn't look right they
all didn't look right and like you're
throwing the trash get rid of them
because they they didn't set right on my
bed and I would go walk to the corner of
the room and look at my bed again and go
back and mess it up and fix it again and
go back and mess it up and and I I was
just like yeah but you know what I
figured it out just one pillow on the
bed and everything's fine I know what I
mean but then when the windstorm
happened I couldn't do I couldn't like
turn on my lights and I couldn't go do
my normal setup that I would do every
day to start my day that's when I was
like and my grandparents saw that it was
like why why can't you just move why
can't you just continue your day without
doing these things that's when we all
realized like oh okay
he needs he needs to do a bit more than
just this like it just became a real
problem because it was just like I just
realized I was I was trapped like I
really was genuinely like very
comfortable and fine being like I'm
never gonna go outside again and and
that's okay and everyone's like that's
not okay it might and in my mind I was
just like why not why is that did you
make any videos at that time yes see and
that's what I'm saying as I was making
videos almost all the time during this
period cuz I was inside I was in my room
kind of trapped anyways so it was just
like it was just like I was playing with
the internet chatting with the internet
staying social and could people from my
perspective thinking about it I don't
think I could tell that about you I
wouldn't know I I there was no there was
no transparency about that no no no not
not not really not not till I finally
moved out of my grandparents house and I
made a video called farewell room where
I kind of opened up about how the
revenue that I've been making was paying
for these like ridiculously expensive
pills that I had to start taking and I
was just I actually started crying in
the video and I and I I just like you
or the reason that I am leaving my room
YouTube is the reason I'm leaving my
room because it it worked out to where I
could pay for it and yeah
so YouTube really helped me sit at this
table right now I mean it just it did
even though they had no idea that's what
they were doing when they were watching
my videos I mean I needed it yeah I
needed it and was that I mean once you
got proper medication and it sounds like
consultation or counseling however you
want to yeah it was like a strong fear
process of just like having to go
through things and and just like trying
things and it not working right
upsetting my stomach for like two weeks
and like it it was some serious medicine
to the point where they were like you
can't just take it you have to ease
yourself into it and I was like what
that's terrifying so and so what was
this specific diagnosis it would it was
just it was like severe
obsessive-compulsive disorder and it
wasn't they were like we're not writing
down that you have agoraphobia but it
sure sounds like you have early symptoms
what is that you're leaving your room oh
and it you know wasn't anything germ
based or anything it was just I just I
literally was just like I'm not going
out there anymore I don't need to yeah
and in my mind it for a long time it was
totally fine like in my mind to just say
that was not a crazy thing to say it was
just like that's it
and I would drive people crazy like
looking back I canceled on people so
much there are so many things that I
would just wouldn't do cuz it was too
far away
that's why seven eight nine the night
for 789 I remember calling Kevin being
like I'm not going to do it he's like
you're going and I was like I'm not
going and he was like if you're not on
that plane man when we land I'm gonna be
so sad and I was just like I'm gonna go
but I'm willing to stay for like an hour
and then it ended up like it like I was
saying it just kind of like opened my
eyes and I was just like I am so glad I
came to this well
you go back to the reception that you
were having on YouTube and what you did
a no.9 has kind of become a staple for
what a lot of guys are doing now there
are people there are guys who are just
good-looking guys you know how to
connect with people as vloggers and
that's what they do that's their career
you definitely I don't know how
conscious it was I don't know if just
because that's not you or was there a
conscious decision to say I'm not gonna
take that path even though there might
be more revenue more subscribers etc I
don't know it was never a conscious
decision it was just kind of his gut
feeling it was just like well I know I
know what my end game is my end game is
to be an artist that's always been my
you know my real in-game in in and and
at the same time I've always I've always
wanted to keep pushing myself and see
what I can get away with and so
eventually it was just like I like
vlogging but what else can I do you know
and what else can I you know and then it
started getting into to more of the
editing side of the whole thing where I
was like man I really like just editing
the footage and seeing what I can how I
can manipulate footage and then it
started in the glitch work and then it
started into just like the whole realm
of also you know okay well if I am gonna
make a video why not have Kyle and do a
sketch like do something like mm-hmm
real and and and edit it and make it
look nice
so yeah I mean I just kind of never I
never it was never like this or that and
I'm picked that it was just kind of like
the flow of me I think it just like
where I was heading in my mind and you
tried a lot of different things and and
so to bring back the the Kyle thread
mm-hmm he came in and you said we're
gonna my channel is gonna feel different
it's going to be more sketch orient yes
that was for a period of time yes and
that was that was when I decided after
the after I dropped out of college and
was feeling a lot better I was like Kyle
you're we're gonna get a place and he
was in school too and I was like I'm
gonna have you leave school I'm gonna
have you leave school and I had a talk I
had a conversation with his mom and I
was like here's the thing
he's my best friend he knows me I feel
like we could do this
just give me a year just give me a year
of his time and and she was she was fine
with it and he was cool with it and
literally like two weeks later I bought
an apartment and I was like let's do
this every Thursday and it became every
Thursday we put out something and that
year we did and we did it for we did it
for a while we did it for a long time
and then yeah that was that was it that
was like the norm just okay man just as
long as we get something up on Thursday
let's just brainstorm brainstorm
Thursday brain strains from Thursday and
where did that at the end of that year
where did that leave the you as an
artist and the tutee and your friendship
because because you parted ways right
well officially we did it we did it for
like a good three years like we moved a
few times together and then our last
move his girlfriend moved with us who is
a sweetheart she's great and then and
then right there at the end when YouTube
started my YouTube started going down
and things started getting tricky where
is this like hey man I I have no money I
have no money right now I'm sorry I
can't pay us and it got to the point
where I was just like you can go this is
my baby I'm staying with this and so I
mean we're still super good friends I
still hang out with them all the time it
was just like I I could see something
happening and I was just like we had a
lot of fun man get out of here you know
and and just and he got a place with her
and he went back to school and that's
what he's doing right now and I'm
thrilled for him I think it I think it
was an awesome moment in our friendship
like it it's this time period where I'm
just like man we were infinite we were
just like living this cool dream like I
remember when I turned 21 he picked me
up from the airport because I was
shooting something in Los Angeles and he
was just like dude we're gonna stop and
you're gonna buy US beer yeah and you
and we we took the beer back to our
apartment and I was just like this is so
cool like we are just making videos just
all those things that teachers said that
would send us the detention for we're
doing now on camera and making money and
it's our careers and we're having so
much fun and yeah it was just like this
that was like the period that was the
ethos that was like the the period of
the sketches that's where it was
constantly sketches and that's why
sketches have kind of not died out on
the level if I'll still do them but mmm
now it's just back to just my mind being
alone right now
and and with my youtube channel like
being so terrible with views it's just
like now is my time where I'm just like
let's do all those weird art things that
you were afraid to do and when the
audience was real hard when they were
really like demanding rushing in and
demanding yeah so so now I'm just kind
of having like this like free-for-all
where I'm just like I'm gonna upload
it's an hour video of gradients at what
point what do you think led to you said
things started to decline over the
course of you know when it was sketch
focused was that a factor at what point
did the physical makeover happen which
is aka you got a haircut yeah did that
happen in that same time frame um
actually it happened kind of in the
middle of the sketch period and it was
it actually didn't play as big of a role
as I thought I was actually really happy
but everyone you know everybody makes me
hissy fit when anything changes on the
internet especially such glorious locks
like mine so give it give us kind of
that the backstory of the change because
yeah I'm thinking a lot went into that
and it meant a lot to you it did mean a
lot to me I just wanted to I just wanted
to like prove to myself that it wasn't
just a haircut like it was just I I
meaning your success oh yeah like I'm
I'm putting a lot of work into these
things and if it's really just how I
combed my bangs that day then let's cut
the bangs off and see what happens so
you describe it as a test yeah if I'm
not if this is what it's really all
about then I'm not in right cuz I just
didn't seem like a I mean who wants to
live their life buy a haircut I mean
what if my hair were to fall out I have
no choice for that so yeah it's just
like that's ridiculous that's ridiculous
so yeah I just kind of started pushing
my own limits and like I said went and
then when Kyle and me you know when I
was like you go do it I'm gonna keep
doing live lava live because I mean at
the core of everything it's always been
just me just mine inviting people in and
out yeah it it's just that it is what it
is now today how did you balance seeing
the channel views decline with a desire
to create certain things I mean was it
there's a tension there do I regain what
works best or do I do what I want to do
is that was that at work I think I'm
still struggling with that cuz every
once in a while I die
I think that's that's where I'm at right
now that's the big thing with me right
now is I I is I I'm not sure what to do
I really love live love a live I really
do but from a financial standpoint it's
just not enough you know now it's just
kind of a hobby now and and it kind of
breaks my heart when I see people being
like why don't you post anymore and I'm
just like I'm working I'm trying to pay
my rent but you're you're moving to LA I
am got you've got a girlfriend it seems
serious serious because you're like
putting her she's on the channel yeah I
know and that was a that was a big thing
- yeah how did how did those things fit
in to where you're what you don't what
you don't know you're doing yeah well
she was just kind of like an accident
like I wasn't I wasn't looking for a
girlfriend I was about to move to LA at
the time and then I met her and I was
like I have to stay and get to know you
you're fantastic where have you been
hiding how did you meet her Megan Megan
I met her on Facebook I met her through
Facebook we had a bunch of mutual
friends and it was like do you know
Megan and I was like I don't know Megan
who is Megan click and I met her for
coffee and we ended up talking for like
7 hours we had mutual friends yeah and
you messaged her we have mutual friends
according to face I just added her and
then messenger Indiana was just like hey
we have mutual friends did she know your
she that was one thing that we did talk
about when she was like you you just
make videos online right and I was like
I still do I still do and she's like
yeah yeah I remember back when I was in
high school some kids were watching them
where you wear v-necks and usher cologne
and stuff and I was like yeah it'sit's
it's different now but I still do that I
actually just shot a something earlier
that day and I told her about it and she
was like so it's cool that you still do
it and I was like you should watch a few
before we date again because you might
not want to date me because I was like
it's definitely still happening like I
didn't want her to like not know that it
was like my main deal but yeah she she's
totally cool with it going back two
years you had in mind to move to LA yeah
have the reasons changed are they the
same is the how related to wanting to
make a go at it again or redefining
yourself on we all through YouTube is
the move or is it just like there's just
more opportunities for what you're
passionate about as an artist I think
it's a little bit of both I think this
time around I have like I'm Marty like
I'm coming out here with work you know
I'm really I want to come out here
because it is out here there's more
hands out here that get it and I mean
there are people like you right now out
here and I I want to be closer to all
that creativity because I think maybe
it'll it'll one it will help me rekindle
that love for live level live and that
like motivation because when I'm in Ohio
sometimes it's easy to not do it when no
one else does YouTube at all mmm through
the years that the brand has changed and
it's still will and it's still it's
still going to I mean for all I know
when I move out here it might completely
change again from shifting from art to
something I might just film the ocean
every day for a year and I've loaded to
live level live it's not so I just I
always at the end of the day want to do
live level live but you but it you don't
have a business strategy no to make it
work or or a creative strategy that
would make the business work ya know I'm
I'm in know ya know I mean even at the
end of the day I still
we want to upload something there even
if no one's seeing it even if it's not
doing me any good I just I like live
level live I I mean it is me mm-hmm
what do you want to make like just one
of the ideas is well I did just collide
my my art channel mmm
with live love live because I'm sure I'm
trying to make live love live grow into
to actually fit what it is called a
channel it is a place where multiple
things are happening playlists and
taking advantage of the little types of
series that I have like taste some jams
where I just review music but then I
also want there to be like this whole
other section of it where it is just
where my art lives my digital art you
know in terms of those weird video ideas
I have I want I just want it to be a hub
a channel that's just like this is
you're seeing inside my mind for a
little bit and some of its funny and
some of its not do you have I mean do
you have any bigger ideas maybe that's
one video maybe that's a series oh do I
have it like right now yeah um not
really I mean the biggest idea that I've
I've had on the level of recently was
merging the channels and kind of picking
my favorite art videos and re uploading
them to live level live but yeah I mean
I don't know I don't I don't have
anything too crazy planned I know that
when I get out here I'm definitely going
to bring scheduling back just because I
think that'll help you know like an
external commitment yes yes and I think
I'm definitely going to start just
putting my brainwaves back into that
groove because for a long time it hasn't
been for a long time it's just been
stressing about money and stressing
about getting like other projects so
that I can keep my cat fed and you know
so at the end of the day it's just like
there's no there's no time to do live
love live today because I've just worked
all day to make sure that I can pay rent
so I'm really gonna try to time
management a lot better when I move out
here and just try to figure out how I
can make it when it seems like your
relationship with the fans of your
channel and your fans
it's a two-way conversation and there
there has to be some sort of
faithfulness on your part to be like I'm
I want to kind of tell you what I'm
giving you or I want to give it to you
in a way that you can there's some sort
of predictability do you do you sense
that the conversation because you've
tried so many things maybe some things
haven't been responded to that
conversation is broken a little bit yeah
it's just I'm a lot of people still
anticipate coming and seeing that
fringed sixteen-year-old boy and and
it's just it's not that you're 25 I'm 25
I grew up and I grew up online and and
I'm not a character and they're not just
gonna recast me with some new 16 year
old boy that's if that's if there's one
thing that I wish everybody could get
it's that well where can we find the
music cuz you mentioned that oh
soundcloud.com slash might see he'll
like possibly see how might see he'll
mitchell MIT CH e ll MIT space c space h
e ll might see hell is my name oh yeah
it's kind of like I wasn't complicated
yeah I wanted to have a name without
having a name so and my one of my good
friends at the time came up with that
and I was just like that's genius
beautiful I and and I've always loved
you know I'm a with religion and all
that kind of stuff I'm just all about
like space and and believing in
ourselves and stuff and I just I like
kind of poking at it a little bit and
might CL is just like the perfect polka
mm-hmm
and then your prints can be purchased
through district lines mr. Kline's comm
slash live love a live slash art and if
we really want to get inside your brains
we've got to continue watching what
you're going to be doing over the next
few months that live lava live on
YouTube yeah just me on the internet the
ocean videos the ocean videos I possibly
could happen but ya know I mean really
it's just anywhere I'm online
I think of websites as canvases I like
to see what I can get away with and use
them in a different way I mean that's
what I do with Twitter I mean most of my
tweets
like what is he talking about but I just
I
that's just how I like using the
Internet I think it's just one big
beautiful canvas and I'm gonna keep
spray-painting it
well we that's what we want and we want
more of it and we want to see continued
success as you use this canvas so and we
would let you spray paint the the table
but that's no one has done that so we're
just gonna let you Sharpie it I just
want some biscuits guys and there you
have it our ear biscuit with Mitchell
Davis the friendship is solidified the a
byproduct of ear biscuit do you feel
like more of a friend to Mitchell now
let him know on Twitter oh you want me
to let him know on Twitter are you
talking to the peace talks to the people
who are listening to me right now so I
could just tell him his handle is M
Mitchell Davis s it's like Mitchell
Davis flanked by the first letter and
last letter of Mitchell and Davis hmm
it's you know that's just how he rolls
well I gotta say some consonants
bookending with consonants in Mitchell
Davis s we did him hashtag ear biscuits
one of the things I would say if I was
tweeting it in Mitchell Davis s is
thanks for the candor thanks for the
honesty thanks for pulling back the
curtain you know in he was he was so
honest with us and he's been through a
lot and he's got so much of a history I
love hearing the story and I'm excited
about where he's gonna go and he is also
coming as he said to LA he's making the
big move out of Los Angeles but the
problem is is that he says that he wants
to be next to the beach well he said he
I think this was conversation off the
record this was afterward okay I get
confused when we're recording when we're
not right at some point you just have to
stop recording but he did tell us hey
I'm you know I'm from Ohio if I'm gonna
move to LA I want to be near the beach
I'll totally understand totally
understandable but we're like well we're
in the valley
I Drive a minivan I live on a cul-de-sac
you do all those things you will never
see me out well
think you know you don't know this until
you move out here yeah
just how big Los Angeles is and you
think oh you live in LA I live in LA
we're gonna be hanging out everyday even
if you want to hang out with somebody
because Mitchell is the kind of guy that
I want to hang out with definitely once
you separate yourself with a
geographical barrier like a hill a large
my Hill we call it a hill but it's large
and it has like a couple of ways to get
over that hill but they all involve
sitting in traffic for long periods of
time you might as well be on the other
side of the country it's I mean it's
apocalyptic you know here we are I mean
at work we're falling right into it we
are we are talking about it yeah we're
not talking about how to get get places
I mean we're talking about the weather
or we're talking about directions then
we're being very LS not do that but yeah
I mean whenever more YouTube friends are
either here or moving here and I were
you moving to I've never heard anybody
say oh the valley no I mean because I
mean with children maybe I'm very happy
in in the valley yeah but I do feel I
can hear the apologetic tone come across
my lips whenever I'm like where I tell
people I'm living well I I usually say
it it's not saying as if to say I'm in
the now I'm in the valley you don't want
to be in the vest because you're young
and single and you and you know what I'm
saying it's it's 110 degrees today
and my air conditioning is broken right
we are come to the valley apocalypse has
hit my house and I'm you know I'm Wayne
not even going home you gonna leave your
family there as you play that I will say
I'm gonna line them up in the yarn I'm
gonna turn on the garden hose okay well
that's wasteful tooling we're in a
drought you can't do that you can't cool
your family off I'll aim it at their
mouths okay as long as they drink every
bit of now I will say to Mitchell you
are welcome to come to any sort of
get-togethers we have in the value will
be hot it will be a little less cool
it'll it'll actually be less cool and
hotter
which I guess is the same thing in two
different ways it will be less cool
temperature and just the vibe again
you're welcome you're welcome to be a
part of it
and you're welcome to hashtag ear
biscuits let us know what you think of
this whole endeavor you know we really
we live and die by your your support and
your listenership
and your comments and your iTunes
reviews SoundCloud comments so please do
each one of those things in that order
whenever you're awake and whenever
you're listening to this we appreciate
it everybody and we'll speak at you next
week
[Music]
[Music]